قال المتحدث باسم الاونر في القدس كاظم
ابو خلف انما يجري في قطاع غزه تهجير قصري
للسكان لان الجيش الاسرائيلي لم يترك
فعليا اي مكان امن في القطاع وفي مقابله
مع الجزيره نشد ابو خلاف كل من له القدره
بالتدخل لان الوضع خرج عن نطاق
الاحتمال كل قطاع غزه يعني ليس فيه لا
مكان ولا شخص ولا شيء امن الحقيقه الكبر
التي هي يعني واضحه للعيان بشكل كبير انه
لا يوجد حتى مكان يذهب اليه الناس هذه
مساله النزوح انتقل شرقا ثم انتقل غربا كم
مره ستنتقل الناس وليتها تنتقل الى منطقه
امنه يعني حتى الان لا يوجد اي منطقه
اصطلح على تسميتها بانها فعلا منطقه امنه
في قطع غزه المساله هي ليست مساله يعني
انذرناكم وعليكم ان ترحلوا هذا هذا يعتبر
يعني كثير من الخبراء الدوليين صنفوا هذا
الانذار بين مزدوجين على انه تهديد وليس
يعني انذارا انه بما معناه ان شئت ان تبقى
بقيت وان شئت ان تنزح نزحت من سيختار
البقاء وهو يعلم انها مساله وقت قبل ان
يسقط على راسه هو اطفاله ا صاروخ
موجه يدمر البنايه بما فيها ثم يطلب منك
ان تنتقل من الشرق الى الغرب او بالعكس او
من الشمال الى الجنوب وهكذا يعني حقيقه
اسئله كبرى يعني تطرح على كل الاطراف
المعنيه ومن يدعي الحقيقه الوصول او يعني
الدعوه لاتجاه الالتزام باحكام القانون
الدولي عليه ان يدلي بدلوه في هذه المساله
لان الامر اص ا يعني خارج حدود
الاحتمال